we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p a lot of
people commenting on youtube
writing in tweeting posting sending
telegrams and smoke signals about alex
jones and the ban of alex jones from
youtube here's just one caller's
perspective this isn't everybody's view
this is one perspective about the alex
jones youtube ban
hey David this is Sean from Colorado
calling in to give my opinion about Alex
Jones because we've seen a lot of really
stupid commentary because I understand
the free speech angle I understand the
slippery slope but people are stupid
because they don't understand the real
reality behind what Alex Jones is than
the hair endangered Valley zones people
like others others be playing about it
if you watch Alex Jones he's insane
if you don't watch Alex Jones and think
he's insane you're insane or insanely
stupid and you have that constant
barrage of just insanity just be there
for people to consume and agree with and
consider like that's a danger yeah so ok
I think the point is that there's a lot
of insanity going on it seems like the
caller is saying Jones is insane and
people who watch him are insane
I don't think that's actually the issue
I know that the real issue fundamentally
is was anything that was done legally
problematic the answer is no the next
question is whether this sets good
precedent and that's where people are
split one side says he undoubtedly
violated the terms and conditions
YouTube didn't just go and pick a fight
with Alex Jones for no reason it was
probably a combination of the tide
publicly turning against his content
combined with the fact that really he
had been violating YouTube's Terms and
Conditions for a very long time that's
one side nothing happened that was wrong
the other side is and I am sort of in
the middle here although I've expressed
concerns that whether or if you're not
going to literally
enforced to the letter every single
violation of YouTube's Terms and
Conditions when it comes to edgy content
you open yourself up for significant
gray area and subjectivity when it comes
to taking actions like this and that was
the the concern I expressed yesterday
most of the audience seemed to agree
with me but still believe that in this
particular case it was very clearly the
right decision to ban Alex Jones yeah I
mean because there are so so many
examples of him at least potentially
breaking the law when it comes to like
threats of violence that he's made
against individuals and when it comes to
defamation so you can certainly make the
case that he has to get off of some of
those platforms and at their discretion
defamation is civil to the I believe
that defamation is only civil so to say
that it's it's criminal it starts to get
legally ambiguous but certainly when he
does content that leads to people
showing up at comet ping-pong and
physically threatening the individuals
there that I think is the strongest
argument for actual criminal content
that Alex Jones has put out not
everybody in the audience is exactly on
the same page but I do think that there
is sort of a coming together on a
consensus taking place with the majority
of the audience we have such a good
bonus show for you today which you can
access by becoming a member at WWN
pakman.com or by becoming a patron at
patreon.com slash david pakman show I
hope you'll join and I hope to speak to
you on the bonus show